this episode is made possible by Mozilla
stay safe this holiday season by
shopping Mozilla's buyer's guide for
gadgets that respect your online privacy
and security
for those of us born from the early 90s
on we've more or less always had the
internet children born as far back as
the year 2000 probably never had to
visit a library to finish a book report
or a project over 3.8 billion people
around the world have access to the
Internet and many people are beginning
to consider this access to be a basic
human right as the Internet has become
more and more powerful and widespread
governments and organizations have
adopted various techniques for keeping
users safe but in some cases they've
also implemented ways of keeping an eye
on people some even going so far as to
suppress information or limit access to
parts of the web more and more often we
hear stories of large corporations or
the government tracking our browsing
habits and people are beginning to
wonder just how free is the internet
since very early in the days of the
World Wide Web
governments have sought to implement
certain restrictions on what can and
cannot be accessed in their country or
region and many schools in the West
often did the same for different reasons
the extent of internet censorship varies
by regime take China for example the
famous Great Firewall is the Chinese
government's attempt to restrict the
populations ability to organize and
protest as well as suppress the spread
of anti-government ideas the Chinese
people can't access Google Facebook
Twitter or YouTube at least not easily
and have their own alternative social
media platforms all heavily patrolled by
the government in the past the Chinese
leadership was hesitant to acknowledge
the extent of their censorship but more
recently they've begun proudly showing
off their idea of internet sovereignty
and tightening their grip on the web
behind the Great Firewall to the
surprise of many in the West this has
not caused much public outcry among the
Chinese population in addition Chinese
business is booming almost 25 percent of
the world's Internet accessing
population lives behind the Great
Firewall and yet China is the world
leader in e-commerce accounting for 40%
of the global total to many in the West
the Great Firewall seems like an
incredibly oppressive and heavy-handed
approach at keeping the peace but the
Chinese government sees the matter in a
different light as a means to allow for
an economy connected to and competitive
with the outside world while maintaining
a political culture closed off from
Western ideas that might undermine the
strength of the Communist Party
China's internet Tsar Liu Wei said this
path is the choice of history and we
walk the path ever more firmly and full
of confidence he goes on to say that
China has struck the right balance
between freedom and order and between
openness and autonomy most people would
agree that places like the United States
France Germany Canada and other Western
countries represent the exact opposite
of this heavily censored approach
particularly the United States given our
obsession with freedom of speech but
just how free and open is our Internet
is there anything we can't say or access
and just how much do corporations and
the government know about us the United
States is a bit of an oddball in terms
of Internet freedom it's consistently
ranked as among the top 5 most free
countries in terms of censorship but in
2014 the u.s. was labeled an enemy of
the Internet by Paris based NGO
reporters without borders with such
neighbors as China North Korea Russia
and Saudi Arabia while the u.s. doesn't
really censor much content across the
web it is guilty of widespread
surveillance of users browsing habits
and activity in some ways that might not
be seen as such a bad thing
such data-gathering allow search engines
to give you customized shopping results
showing you more of what you search for
many people see this as convenient but
it also encourages more shopping or
allows you to form a little echo chamber
within your search results a slightly
more intrusive and alarming example
actually interfered with my research for
another video for the video in question
I wanted to use a clip of an Isis
recruitment video because I was talking
about extremist groups and the threat
they posted the rest of the world
I searched YouTube and got nothing
strange then I searched Google and still
nothing I tried a few more times then
was greeted with this page our systems
have detected unusual traffic from your
computer of course this is nothing to be
afraid of but it does serve as a
reminder that your browsing habits are
being monitored I was curious about why
YouTube didn't return any relevant
results for my search so I did a little
research it turns out that recently
YouTube has made it so that whenever
someone searches for terrorist
recruitment material or Pro Isis
propaganda there instead presented with
the opposite clearly anti terrorist
content and often videos that make Isis
and other such groups appear
disorganized or helpless it's an
interesting situation on the one hand
this is a clear example of censorship
but on the other hand it's only
censoring content from a group that
actually
calls for the killing of innocent people
this is where things get tricky as the
world becomes more politically and
ideologically polarized thanks to the
internet world governments and companies
are faced with difficult decisions
regarding censorship during the latter
half of 2016
Twitter suspended 377,000 accounts for
promoting terrorism in early 2017
Facebook like YouTube decided to employ
a combination of artificial intelligence
and human content flaggers in an attempt
to find and remove extremist content for
a YouTube this reform was in response to
the so-called ad pocalypse with
advertisers leaving the site in droves
because their ads would sometimes appear
on hateful or extremist videos this of
course led to an overcorrection on the
part of YouTube as thousands of fairly
tame videos were demonetized even some
second thought videos were demonetized
including any videos that mentioned
nuclear weapons or North Korea and
perhaps unsurprisingly the video for
which I needed the Isis recruitment clip
the US isn't alone in censoring
questionable content in France and
Germany most Nazi related and Holocaust
denial websites are blocked communist
symbols and imagery are censored in
Poland Lithuania Ukraine Latvia Moldova
and Hungary South Korea blocked
pro-north Korean sites some Middle
Eastern countries blocked sites related
to the Muslim Brotherhood the common
thread between these instances of
censorship is public approval
most people don't protest such content
being blocked or filtered because it is
alarming or offensive to most of society
but what happens when less globally
offensive sites start getting blocked or
certain sites are throttled we may be
about to find out since early 2017 the
federal government of the United States
seems to have been testing the waters in
preparation for potential adjustments to
Internet freedom on April 2nd the
President signed a bill that released
Internet service providers like AT&T and
Verizon from having to protect consumer
data this move has put a huge amount of
private information in jeopardy and it
looks like just the beginning the
Federal Communications Commission or FCC
is attempting to weaken net neutrality
rules which would allow those same ISPs
to create fast lanes for preferred
Internet traffic while throttling other
traffic sources sources such as people
planning a rally or anti-government
demonstration for example back in 2016
Freedom House ranked the u.s. as having
one of the freest web
in the world but recent events have
placed the u.s. under the country's 2
watch list
marking a possible negative trajectory
and Internet freedom for 2017 and the US
isn't alone of the 65 countries assessed
in 2016
34 have been on a negative trajectory
since 2015 other key findings from the
Freedom House report detailed that
Internet freedom around the world
declined for the sixth year in a row
social media users have begun to face
unprecedented penalties with authorities
in 38 countries making arrests based on
social media post in the past year
worldwide governments are increasingly
going after messaging apps like whatsapp
and telegram which allow for quick and
secure spread of information so while
the United States and the West as a
whole have been a bastion for Internet
freedom for many years it's worth noting
that we may be in for some unpleasant
changes in the near future if the
current trend is as alarming to you as
it is to me do yourself a favor and
check out Mozilla's new buyer's guide
privacy not included in a world where
more and more products connect to the
internet from cars to dolls to salt
shakers there's a real risk of your
sensitive information ending up
somewhere it shouldn't Mozilla has
launched their new initiative to help
people identify internet connected
products that meet their privacy and
security needs
the Mozilla team reviewed dozens of
popular toys consoles exercise gadgets
and smart home accessories ranging from
25 to 900 dollars so there's something
for every budget the guide reviews
products with important questions in
mind questions like does this product
have privacy controls does the company
share data with third parties and does
the company obey child related privacy
rules the end result is an easy list of
products with privacy and security
features just as obvious as their price
if you want to send a message to the
companies that make Internet connected
devices and support second thought while
you're at it make sure to do your
holiday gift shopping with the Mozilla
Privacy not included buyer's guide if
you enjoyed this video consider
subscribing to support the channel and
stay up to date on the latest content
and click the little Bell next to my
channel name to join the notification
squad you can watch my previous video by
clicking here or if you're done learning
for the day come watch me play games
with a friend on my new gaming channel
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next video